most people like to think of themselves
as reasonably well-rounded and that goes
for gaming too
a lot of gamers are willing to pitch in
if their team need something specific
I'm [__] around day not up for debate
I'm ad carry hey boys help ease on the
line guys I'm sorry I have to lose the
ego I'm sorry guys but there are
radicals with their own agendas
individuals who are fully committed to
investing countless hours of repetition
into achieving one particular objective
one-trick ponies legendary martial
artist Bruce Lee once said I fear not
the man who is practiced 10,000 cakes
once but I fear the man who had
practiced one kick 10,000 times and the
one trick is someone who's done just
that
oh maybe like if it's good I cake was so
okay well it's not always specifically a
kick
regardless of what exactly their trick
might be one-trick ponies can be an
infuriating obstacle in team-based
competitive games mainly because their
path to mastery means a refusal to
compromise I am officially a one-trick
hanzo made no I won't switch but where
does this term even come from well it
was used as far back as the late 19th
century to refer to an actual pony that
could only do one trick and yeah I had
no idea but ponies actually do tricks
the bar is pretty low though like
stepping on things and lying down is
apparently impressive for them oh yeah
like what
I've I built so one-trick pony has been
in use for over a hundred years but
what's harder to pin down is when
exactly people started using it
figuratively well according to our
research by at least around 1950 it was
in colloquial use and a 1980 film
written by musician Paul Simon called a
one-trick pony seems to have repopulate
urn now it gives us and that figurative
meaning is of course someone or
something that can only do one thing
effectively so more often than not it's
meant negatively Jim ty Wilder is a
one-trick pony
one-trick pony he's a one-trick pony but
how does one-trick pony
apply to competitive gaming today it's a
label you're most likely to see thrown
around in games where you have to build
a team color like MOBAs or class-based
shooters so don't worry if you primarily
use an OP in counter-strike it doesn't
make you an offer on trip you're just an
offer
however in games like League of Legends
and there's the expectation that players
are able to play more than one champion
because from match to match your
character of choice can be banned or put
by someone else but that hasn't stopped
people from becoming one tricks so the
question then becomes why do it as
expected someone tricks are really just
trying to frustrate other people
drinking heels
versus not feeling about it oh my god in
the way are you know he'll buddy some
are newcomers playing one character
primarily while they learn the game
other one tricks are just trying to
perfect their skills on one hero and the
truth is that most high profile one
tricks and a lot of these games are
usually pretty good at their one-trick
stinks these Dinks sleep that shape the
bully check out this need to say a wall
climb but being unwilling to play
anything but one character can have
consequences if I get one more one trick
no he's a one-trick hog too like are you
supposed to be good at your one trick if
you only play that character and he only
touches [__] hog so sad and you're
not even good with him okay I don't
really care about your shield generator
I mostly care about us having a second
healer at the effort I've actually
realized if Avandia
while being a one-trick might be
incredibly annoying is it worthy of
being a band Allah fence in the
overwatch at least the answer is no the
game's director Jeff Kaplan has said
that while switching your hero to help
your team is respectful
it isn't mandatory as long as you're
actually trying to win and reporting
someone for being a one trick is
actually viewed by Blizzard as an abuse
of the reporting system which has
consequences of its own
we are currently visiting the issue and
will provide updates as
it was at this moment he knew he [__]
up yo okay what the [__] but that
doesn't mean that people will kindly
tolerate one tricks what's more
important five players to join the game
or one player entering the game there's
no one else in the team right here no
one else in this game on this specific
team is enjoying the game
it's enjoying playing the game at all
because of this one person while most
one tricks are fairly harmless many of
the highest profile ones are actively
disruptive like the Symetra one trick
who stream sniped him the tap man by
intentionally throwing games his name is
X R Y Z and he's a Symetra made that
lost me for te lo because I'm just
having so much fun at the game and he's
playing some a few whoa nothing nothing
I could put in turrets around me [__]
like that number
she'll generate around kick of the hill
and then somebody flanks the entire team
and kills my shield Jenna oh boy that's
one of my favorite things to do you know
it's fine though because I'm having fun
even though my team hates me and I'm
also dead inside in League of Legends
one tricks like Damir might throw a game
simply because they don't get to play
their champion of choice or flame their
teammates but does one tricking corrupt
those who engage in it or does the path
of the one trick just attract a specific
kind of player you know I just do things
whether we like it or not
one tricks like Smurfs or boosted
accounts are just part of the online
competitive landscape you can choose to
support these unruly beasts for the
greater good of your team
or you can let them know you're not
taking their [__] a lot of you guys in
the comments think that were one tricks
because we only do cringy endings
yeah exactly we're cringe Mane's not one
tricks was that good to cringe
[Music]